it's hiking time
hiking time
it's hiking
[Music]
put your pants back up please
dude that's not funny that's not funny
so we're on our way to a hike i don't
know anything about this hike popper
just found it he said he found this on
tick tock so i'm actually pretty
interested
uh
in this hike
i was like okay it's gonna be easy or is
it gonna be hard he's like it should be
pretty chill and then i was gonna put on
my my regular just hiking regular shoes
like the you know like not boots but
they're just like they look like running
shoes but they have a bunch of teeth on
the bottom uh trail shoes that's what i
was gonna put on and i'm like i don't
know man sometimes bart tends to like
downplay things where he's like oh it's
gonna be easy and then i'm like hanging
off rocks
excuse me sir what is it going to be an
easy hike
should be unless tick-tock lie to me
they said four easy hikes everyone
should go on in vegas
and this one okay wait but look at that
truck right by your face oh the green
one
yeah thing's nice are you looking at the
weird yellow bronco
no that one's not even in the frame it's
not worth it the bronco is one of the
biggest letdowns i've when they had the
by you or like industrial bronco by ford
like when they were promoting it like
last year or two years ago i was so
excited and then when i saw them in real
life i was like
what what a letdown yeah because you
were supposed to be a wrangler killer
and i think i still like the jeep ring a
little better okay but is this hike hard
um i know i threw you off but thank you
for jumping back on board i'm always
here you know me i'm always down to play
all right no the hike it should be easy
unless tick tock light to me because i
said like wide nice dirt roads
it looked like people go there and walk
their dogs
i know okay can i tell you guys a secret
but you can't tell anybody
you can't even tell bar okay no bart
actually knows about it okay we you can
tell people you can tell people it's not
that big of a singer um but we've
actually been looking at dogs and by we
i mean bart like crazy all i said to
bart was um
uh what did i say i'm like oh man i
really miss a dog and then on a hike we
saw a really cuny dog
and bart was like asking the owner what
breed is it and then i want to say that
was like two three weeks ago ever since
then pop bear's been frantically
searching for this specific dog what is
it called
uh it goes by many names it can go by an
australian coulee you can go buy a texas
healer you can go by blue healer but
they're all from the the cross-bredded
australian shepherd with another dog and
that's the breed
and it's so cute
and like i'm trying to stay logical and
level-headed here and going no not right
now you know we're barely settling in we
haven't really fully understood like
vegas living just yet like we travel
back and forth from california a lot but
then my heart
my little furry heart is like let's do
it let's get four of them let's do it
right now f this hike let's go get it so
i'm trying to stay
centered here because i really want
these [ __ ] dogs they're so damn cute
all right quick little pit stop all that
talking got us hungry
so i'm in centennial hills which is a
different area of vegas a lot of people
think
vegas is just one city but it's not it's
actually like la you know like in la you
have little tokyo you have glendale you
have k-town you have santa monica like
all of those are different pockets vegas
is the exact same way there's summerland
northwest southwest centennial hills
anthem henderson and green valley like
there's all enterprises all these
different areas so i'm in the centennial
hills area which is in the northwest and
we're about to go on the hike alone
mountain as we were talking about and so
i looked up on yelp because we got
hungry while we're talking we found this
breakfast spot called my
garage
do you know where you're gonna get
are you stuck between two three are you
trying to copy me is that what or we
could share maybe
okay it's gonna be kind of a point
what is it
so i'm kind of backing off taika at this
moment so that's why this is my choice
bacon off am i gonna steal his pancake
well i'm not gonna steal it just finish
it
i'm gonna get the 16 ounce t-bone steak
and eggs okay
and the reason i'm getting that is
because this guy's gonna get the junior
cakes which is three small pancakes one
egg one bacon or sausage yeah he's not
gonna finish it so i'm like oh and i can
have some of this
okay i don't know why but today i just
saw a country fried steak and i never
get that i love it that's one of the
worst and unhealthiest things in the
world and i don't know why i want it so
bad but i've been watching why you want
something unhealthy that's literally
your that's all you want like yours
but i stay away from it all the time i
know
yeah it's just not i don't know why i
don't want it you always want it that's
true i always want i don't know why i'm
giving in today
maybe we just it's holidays you're like
[ __ ] it's something yeah it's the
christmas the it's the music huh it's
the holiday music they got eggnog in
here maybe she gets an eggnog too i've
never had it really yeah it has alcohol
i don't think you'll like it it's like
kind of rummy a little bit of rum but
you can get it without it it's thick
it's thicker than a milkshake in and out
milkshake um the only thick drink i've
ever had is this champorado yeah it's
like that thick
really yeah
i like it it's cinnamony
not
mangy yeah i don't know why i never got
it
i mean we just never bought it
okay holidays
[Music]
so originally we're just gonna get
regular coffee but i was looking around
this place this place is called my
garage so that the core is pretty cool
where they have like license plates
roll-up door a craftsman table for the
drinks and then i see
logos of coffee so we're like we better
change our regular coffee to a latte
good call mama
gonna mix it no i'm not
oh you're just gonna get the chocolate
yeah this only part that doesn't have
coffee chocolate milk foam
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
of course you would love that
[Applause]
and like always taika always gets the
chocolate chip
this one just wants chocolate for
breakfast
i love his ducks
i got my country fried steak with eggs
and hash browns
[Music]
yes thank you thank you damn you
big manly woman you
hey good job knife from fork you
gentlemen yeah you want to show you
you're a gentleman dude
hold the fork lower so it helps you hold
the pork right here
okay
you'll figure it out good job
i can't do it it's okay
this is
my first country fried steak
in probably like two years
look at all that gravy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right definitely change the plans
because we finished the breakfast i
followed the yelp
to lone mountain trail
it's a bridge and i think that's the
trail where it's like a city water
water route water supply
and i guess the lesson is
what's that
this is not strong
the bridges is wrong you can tell by the
architecture yeah but it's not strong
how are you supposed to do it right then
[Music]
yeah that's what they're missing i could
tell
but anyways um it goes without saying
don't trust everything
you see on tick tock because once again
i got duped they told me this is one of
the must go to hikes
in
vegas
and it looks like
oh yeah and it's called lone mountain
trail look it's actually right there
but that does not look like a fun
trail at all it does not look like
nature it does not look like a trail at
all
so yeah we'll go change the plans we'll
go find some other place to go hiking or
we can just go
decorate our house for christmas
is that what you want to do
living in vegas you see some of the
weirdest [ __ ] ever this is some pretty
weird [ __ ]
i've seen here only and i grew up in la
and ellie's already [ __ ] weird but
this is like a different level of weird
heist of life huh check out no it's not
check out these guys
no
do be quiet
he has magic somehow he could just stay
in the windows going guys
i got cut that bro the windows went down
[Music]
yeah when tiger says akka kadabra the
windows just go down by themselves he
does magic do it again i didn't get that
bruh
[Music]
so after breakfast and a failed hike
we came home and we took a cuny nap you
can tell from
all the blankets out such a nice day of
relaxing
but i didn't get the hike bug out of my
system
and
yeah i got hike bugs
and i've been staring
at this hill
for i don't know how long for how many
years
god damn it
and so i'm like why don't we try
climbing that one have an adventure
so we're gonna try
to actually
go up here and climb our neighborhood
hill
hey what do you got over there what are
you eating
ding-dong
why do you point your butt all the time
hey you got a nice one oh damn
you're getting my chemistry going
hey what are you doing
he's always gonna one-up he's a natural
comedian he's always gonna heighten the
joke oh my god i gotta show you guys
later
what i posted on instagram
these two were at a supermarket let's
just say this dude ended up pulling out
his wee-wee but we didn't record it beat
you well yeah of course i have decency
i'm not freaking mexican and do crazy
stuff like that like me
he's like i gotta up one no i i have
class unlike you
you classless person
with those ashy ass elbows and knees
yeah dude you're not fooling anybody
all right time to take our community
off road
that way though we gotta hop the fence
then there's gotta be another way no i
looked i literally looked on the
satellite images and the only way is if
we drive all the way out of the
neighborhood so it's just way easier to
just go to the neighborhood no trust me
and then even look into people's houses
no we don't have to look at people's
houses we just gotta hop the community
fence we're not gonna look into
anybody's houses
okay trust me you've done this before
you trust me right you see he doesn't
know anybody what are you talking about
he's four you know he could vote almost
he's 12 years away from voting
wait 12 no 40 14 years
right are you down to vote
what
you better practice your american right
young man
okay you're the lead i follow you mr
leader we're not looking into nobody's
yard
yep this is our house
with no backyard
is the neighborhood
all right we both made it safely over
from over there
now we're crossing this flood drain
we're right here right where it goes
you gotta go that way see those two
black things over there the rules
those two black girls yeah we'll follow
you or follow you
i like following the rules dude this
makes me nervous you would never have
been a youtuber if you want to follow
the rules
it's in our blood
[Music]
can't believe you're teaching them how
to hop a fence
that's where the trail is right no i
want to climb this mountain this
mountain right here that's the one i've
been like i've been dying to see what's
on the other side cause you know at
night sometimes you see lights and stuff
i never know what's on the other side
what happens
we gotta go let's go we never go over
the gate you're right and that's what
we're trying to figure out what's going
on on that side
let's go mama come on you slowpoke
people
you follow me right here i follow you
you follow me
oh mama found a good place that one's
way more stable than over here
here i'll follow you and then you could
go on that okay
you don't want going down to more stable
look mama's out there already
you want to climb it this way the
old-fashioned hardcore way
okay
okay
yeah you want to do it the tough way
right good job
oh that's cuny
look we made it up pretty far it went
from here
and we were down there at one point
that was a little staircase we crossed
out over here
i think we're about halfway or maybe a
third of the way
wow that's vegas right there
let's see if i can see the casinos let
me get something more stable
oh yeah right there
there's the casinos
good job tyka you're doing so good you
little climber
you're gonna be a future
future rock climber free solo dude
huh
[Music]
wow the view behind you is insane
is that magma
what is that it's magma
i don't know what you're saying did he
just say
the magma comes up becomes lava and it
sticks there
sometimes we gotta talk to each other
figure out what he's saying
you kicked it off
don't yell you're gonna disturb the
neighbors
look tycho we're almost there almost at
the top
that's the finish line
that's when we go i rule the world and
you can go ah
yes
yeah the animals are on the other side
oh yeah
[Music]
hey hey you're gonna pull me down
okay
so we made it to the top
it's really high now actually
and the view
is
in
sane
what
that is crazy
i don't even know what this is just like
uncharted territory
what is that
what is that is it a community it's a
golf course yeah
oh crazy look this is a trail
so people ride mountain bikes
that's a mountain bike trail
oh so cool
damn people come all the way up here
wow look at that sun
insane
wow
i'm so glad we came up here
and i just want to go
we'll figure it out
good job monkey i can't believe you
climbed the big mountain by yourself now
you have to say something say what give
your speech
go
what would you like to say i don't know
or do you want to sing a song as a wing
yeah
see i'm on top of the world
love watching movies with taika because
he has that
don't need a character
look we're missing it look
at it
[Music]
i love watching movies with them because
this commentary is so funny
it's the funniest thing ever it makes
the movie ten times better yeah oh i
missed it okay go let me see oh you got
the web what is he gonna do next
don't block it okay don't block it
i'm looking
whoa
[Laughter]
you guinea guys
[Music]
stop doing that
oh no take a sleeping again not again oh
my god
don't throw it in the trash
what
[Music]
oh no he's sleeping again let's throw
out the trash
why is this guy always sleeping
[Music]
okay
you like that yes oh my god i have a
thing that's going to last a long time
[Music]
oh no it's like a sleeping
i guess that's sleeping again are you
kidding me
oh my god
do you guys see everything that's coming
out
like
this huh
like
this huh
what time do you think it is
i think it's what time is it christmas
what's your favorite christmas song
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't know sorry did i miss like
i missed 20 of the notes
it just got a little
different really a little bit monkey
come here
mama
and an
ad
well that's pretty strong dude
can you help mom open the chapacos
hey chill dude leave it leave it leave
it leave it on the floor leave it on the
floor leave it on the floor by the way
you can get
our barbell brigade christmas sweater
you can show them the christmas sweater
at barbell brigade.com
you are a strong young man
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
iron
i'm hanging oh my god
oh
look at that
that looks good
that looks really
this good quite crazy over there
[Laughter]
hey you better pick up those pillows
right here like this
and you just gotta make sure it's it's
secured like look at this look at my
hands make sure it's secure before you
let it go
and it works
oh
[Music]
so me and tyka have been decorating this
tree
and i told him he can put the ornaments
literally anywhere he wants
i thought he's going to space it out but
he put all of them at the bottom
like a why are all the ornaments
together down
[Music]
because they're there friends yeah
that's bent can you fix it
yeah
good job
he's strong
hey good job
where's that one going is that going to
the bottom of the two no
put up there
good job dude oh my god
this gets crazy
[Music]
so this is our christmas decoration so
far
got this guy done
ma bear set the nice dining table
not done yet but it's the nice red and
green colors
we got all of these ornaments out still
got to place them somewhere
and then we also have
what you do what you got going on up
here i don't know i don't like it really
what's wrong with that situation go
outside you can see it okay
it looks good over here we got a nice
christmas tree merry christmas
nice lights over here flamingo
all right let's see what it looks like
outside
let's see
hey move careful dude
oh it looks nice
it looks nice mama
you don't like it yeah okay okay go
outside i'm gonna go inside now go
outside
that's that's what we got going on so
far
and uh
we gotta get ready for bed because
tomorrow is a weekday
so it's time for work time for school
time goes by so fast i know
no week day dude
let's go back to school tomorrow
so tell everyone good night monkey how
is it that you just started school
literally your whole life and you're
already over it how does that happen
got 12 more years buddy
he loves his school though
slow motion
what did they tell you about putting
stuff in my face
i find you you tell people good night
then he's so scared of me can you tell
yeah shaking
you tell people good night
say good night
what did i say
say good night everybody good night
that's all you get that's all you get
you can't ask for more that's it